are you saying uh designing jordan is
better than winning a grammy
it's right up there it's right up there
as a kid
that grew up idolizing jordan
loving the shoes such an imperative
integral part of my childhood to be able
to
design my own jordan i mean it was
it was the dream what up everyone it's
mclemore
and this right here is my life and
sneakers
[Music]
gq all right the newest pair of shoes
that i have
just got them haven't even laced them
yet is these jordan ones
the jordan one high neutral gray
85s i've wanted these for a long time
you know they came with a little jordan
tag breaking down
the history not even this is just what
it came with this is the og
pair of gray laces and the leather seems
pretty good
it's beautiful to me and you know what's
gonna be even more beautiful is when i
actually lace them up
and i beat these up and they look like
they're from 1985
because that is the way that this shoe
was intended to be worn
was to beat the hell out of it and i'm
gonna do that
you just gotta you gotta [ __ ] these up
man
you gotta beat this shoe up and you
gotta go out
and you gotta wear it that's what shoes
were intended for
i mean if you look at like a pair of
11's like patent leather
jordans they're not gonna look as good
beat up
you know the patent leather creases in a
way that just doesn't quite hit the icy
sole when that turns like
yellow a pair of 11's just doesn't look
as good
the first four jordans to me
look better beat up cause like that's
what people used to wear their sneakers
like this is like when it was coming out
in the 80s like people used to beat
their [ __ ] up and
it it had a certain flavor to it we're
so precious now it's like
walking like this trying not to crease
the toe and i remember doing that back
in the day like
my first pair of fours was definitely
you know i don't think i
i bent my toes for like two months
but i'm probably gonna get two pairs of
these to be honest
i just feel like these are ones that i
won the collection i want to have a
fresh pair for later on when i want to
beat them up i want to beat these up
right now
the thing is i get rid of shoes like i
looked at all of the shoes that i have
and i was like i don't have like a ton
of
old old shoes but these are one of the
pairs that are the oldest
it is a legends of the summer
justin timberlake jordan 1. shout out to
jt
another goat along with michael jordan i
got them probably
in 2013
i want to say they're bright as hell
like if homegirl from wizard of oz
dorothy
had a pair of jordans these would be
them they are
sparkly they are shimmery we got the wax
laces
on deck on the side just in case you
want to go to white that might actually
look pretty hard
there's certain shoes that i'm like man
i'm not gonna i'm not wearing them
i just have never had an occasion to
really stunt
in the rubies i haven't been invited to
that party yet
if i was to rank these with the rest of
jordan ones
um they might be like uh
42. um
they're not my favorite they're not
like what do you wear these with i don't
even know if justin timberlake ever wore
these
but a really nice gift it was a really
nice gift jt if you have any idea uh
what i could match these with please let
me know um
no ideas over here at all
rarest these are jordan sixes
earl thomas a pe that was made for him
they got the 29 in the back cleats
seahawks colors
and the material is just fire after the
seahawks won the nfc championship game
we were back in the locker room
celebrating
and um earl had these and i commented on
him he was like bro you can have him
signed them on the spot gave them to me
i mean the sixes are some of my favorite
jordans period but
to get a game-worn pair on the game the
nfc championship game that we
won to go on to win the super bowl i
performed at halftime
um it's just a very special pair of
shoes
and i'm not a big signature guy but for
some reason i was just in the moment and
i was like bro chinese
and um and he did they got a little bit
of blood up here
that's some 49er blood up at the top
yeah we won that game
i would imagine myself and earl thomas
are the only people with this shoe
in the entire world which makes it the
rarest
and worth 1.2 million dollars
[Music]
aha these guys this is a very rare pair
of shoes man you know
a lot of people might not be hip to the
mellows this was the first thing that
jordan
brand hollered at me about was doing a
mellow i was like i would love to do a
mellow
and i would also love to do a jordan but
this was the first thing that they let
me do
i just flooded the whole thing northwest
salmon we got the shark face gang
at the bottom this is the old shark face
gang logo that we had
we got the flight plate i feel like if
you were like a freestyle walker you
could
you could grind really easily with the
with the flight plate
yeah these are these are dope man i
don't wear them they're very much a hoop
shoe
they only made i believe 23 pair
and not many people have these
obviously because of 23 pairs but like i
definitely still have some in the garage
let's put it that way team jordans it
hasn't been my thing as much
and no disrespect i think what's good
about it is for a lot of people
um it's an entry point into jordan's
and you know for being real like jordans
are super expensive like even those
those 85 ones are like you know they
were like uh yeah those are going to be
229 or whatever i'm like damn for some
ones
i think that there's like this stigma
with like looking down on team jordan's
like
oh that's not the you know you got the
bammer jordans
those are bootleg and i might you know i
might think that in my head
but actually it's great accessible point
and they're still expensive it's not
like we're talking about like some
payless shoes
here like there's still some bread but
it's just not you know
yeah we're gonna get you for the 225.
this was kind of my
gateway into designing
the jordan sixes they were gonna leave
it at this like that was the plan
but you know i have a nostalgia a
connection
to the past with jordans and um
you know luckily they were super
accommodating let me do a six as well
[Music]
these are the clay sixes
man yeah i got to design these my
collaboration with jordan
ranks with all of the amazing things
that i have done with music
that i have gotten to do through music
this has to be
top i mean it's damn near just
one period you know the little pink jump
man cute as hell all pink and salmon and
[ __ ]
the wax laces icy soul pull
tab they're just nice i mean we got the
shark face gang in the back
and like all of these things like
putting the logo in the back
this was at the time a rare
thing like they didn't really let
everyone do that that got pes
and i remember like we had because they
wanted to do just the regular
air with the jumpman but the nike air
that to me symbolizes the og
era of of jordans and something that's
really special and
and i was like yo can we do the nike air
in the back and this was
before they had retroed anything and
they were like
hard no definitely not putting the nike
air in the back so i was like can i do
my look you know i'm down there i'm
trying to spin [ __ ]
i'm manipulating i'm trying to hustle
and uh
we ended up on my own logo in the back
which was super fire
um definitely had to go through some
bureaucracy to do that
you know we sampled a bunch we sampled
like five different pairs and i really
wanted to do like a flooded
jade color green but i also had these
at a certain point they were like look
like if you really want to do two we can
do two
which was like oh my god
yes yes let's do two
and for the most expensive pair of shoes
that i own emerald city sixes
i have seen them online for up to 20k
maybe even 25. they're pricey
the idea was cactus and clay and my guy
lace helped me think of that
these are just special like there's just
nothing like these
23 pairs made and i think jordan had
some made himself
jordan when he first saw these was like
i don't like green i don't [ __ ] with
green
up until this point to my knowledge
there wasn't really a green pair
of jordans he didn't like green i was
like whatever these are about to slap
not tripping at all we need to get away
from
the red and the black michael we need to
switch it up we need to push the
envelope
and sure enough uh he listened
jordan listened and they let me they let
me do it
i think the reason why they're more than
the clays i think they just stand out
and again the fact that they were if not
these some of the first green jordans
ever
um the color is super unique it makes
sense why these would be just a little
bit more
than the clays but they're both going to
run you a bag
did you have one of your shoes you know
i think that there's something
special about of course having a pair of
shoes that have
you know there's only 23 pairs made of
them uh
would i have wanted a bigger release
um sure yeah
but maybe something slightly different
for the friends and family you know i
think that that's what makes
i mean we're talking about that
exclusivity that thing like i can't have
those like that is what drives the
sneaker market that is what tells the
story that is what
we all buy into so i think that if i was
to have done
a more general release having it be
slightly different than
you know maybe these maybe you just have
the shark on the back of these ones but
not on the general release something
that
differentiates the two would have been
preferred but
um i'm very happy with the way that it
turned out in terms of
um 23 pairs i think that it's a cool
story
how do you feel about uh travis scott
i think it's dope i mean what what
travis has done with jordan has been
incredible
i've really liked his collaborations you
know he's just pushed the envelope
i really like what he's done with jordan
and they've obviously given him
a lot of creative um you know it's a
different era it's like we're coming off
of like
the virgil era where he completely redid
all these
all these shoes all these classic shoes
um
nike jordan they're obviously in a place
right now where it's like look we can't
just keep
putting out slightly different colors of
the same shoe
it's not going to work in the long run
and you know i think virgil really
cracked the code with that i think
travis picked up the ball and ran with
it and it's and it's you know if you
look back
it's cool to have been you know in 2013
or whatever these were um 14 to have
been kind of
you know the first person to uh to
really get some creative license to do
something
outside the box all right you probably
noticed
that most of my shoes are
nike if i was to pick a shoe that is not
nike that doesn't have the swoosh
i'm going with the classic
chuck taylors even though nike owns
converse like a converse is a converse
this this is not a nike you know out of
all of the shoes that i have performed
and i i go back to chuck's
i don't know why they're not comfortable
they probably have killed
my arch support or lack thereof but
there's something about
chucks that are just timeless
they just feel different their the
material is more heavy duty
it's kind of like a carhartt jacket
almost
of a fabric at the show you know i have
a bunch of outfit changes
these are gonna go with every single
outfit change that i have at the show
um i love these
we're coming in with the hoka ones
these shits are just comfortable the
midsole
is like [ __ ] three inches i feel like
i'm a better dad when i wear them i can
walk hella fast
when i think of the dad's shoe i think
of the monarchs that's the number one
dad shoe to me
obviously they became very trendy pete
carroll
was at the forefront of that trend for
years we used to always talk about
pete's shoes like what is he doing
like someone needs to tell pete like
those don't look good
sure enough pete was right the entire
time
pete knew that things were gonna circle
back
yeah it's it's dope to pare down some
some like more flashier [ __ ] on top with
just like a chill-ass dad shoe
like i'll wear a suit with a dad's shoe
i'll wear a iced out watch
with the dad shoe just let me just be a
dad out here
let me not flash let me drop my kids off
at school in the phantom but hop out
with the hocus
okay it's like humility in a phantom
all right most underrated
these sb's i love the kilty
the kill tie the kilty i'm not sure how
you say it
but i love this [ __ ] yeah it's kind of a
tartan argyle
we'll go with that it's a tartan argyle
in the back
this is classic golf you know if you
look at a lot of the old golf shoes
that you know footjoy was putting out
other companies back in the 60s the 70s
they did this i feel like these are the
reason why i put them in the most
underrated is because i feel like
the internet would be like oh man those
are ugly
you know why would you wear that on your
shoe like you wear it on your shoe
because no other shoe has
this and you can take it off i think
they're underrated man
but now that i actually think about it
i've never worn them so maybe they're
not underrated
maybe they should just stay in the
closet for
the most unexpected shoe a new passion
of mine
is the game of golf that's right golf
never would have thought that i would
have been into golf
and not only into golf i am absolutely
obsessed with the sport of golf
and i am coming out with my own
golf clothing company called buggy boys
one of the cool things that has already
transpired
um is that one of our prints this is
called
the dog leg print it's kind of an
all-over print
aerial view of a golf course foot joy
made a pair
101s for me
to wear and um i love this shoe man
i i've always been inspired by golf
clothing the og tartans
the plaids the arnold palmers the lee
travinos
the dudes that just had style back in
the day
that's always been a huge place of
inspiration for
the clothes that i wear currently you
know that i've been wearing from
the jump so i really love footjoy makes
like classic
old golf shoes so they did three pairs
of
of one of ones for me very gracious
i love the shoe i love the print and i'm
just pumped to be able to put the brand
into the world and yeah you can go to
buggyboys.com
bogeyboys.com and you can shop all the
gear
but we don't have these for sale these
are just your boys
i didn't do this the way that you wanted
me to i didn't do a top five of all time
i did some
of all time i did some that i just like
right now
some beat ass cement
fours with the nike air on the back
creased as hell this to me symbolizes my
childhood this symbolizes
my first introduction to jordan's
it's just it holds a special place in my
heart man
of course you got the air bubble that
you cannot see through you can't see
sh i'm sure if i try these on yeah
i could just break these i kind of want
to
it's a special shoe it's definitely the
top five
we're talking top five you gotta go with
red ones
so this is the band shoe also called the
bread this is the air jordan one this is
really what started
it all these are from o1 second
re-release
i mean in a way you could really say
this shoe started
sneaker culture i mean i don't i don't
think that's a stretch
you have some of the most iconic
pictures of jordan
dunking on cats in this shoe
so these are the oregon duck threes
now i picked the oregon duck ones
because i wanted to um
flex on the internet these ones are
special because they're the pit crews
these were given to me i i believe we
did a show
at the university of oregon and they
gave me a pair of these
i mean just the oh in general like the
embroidery is super thick
the pit crew is hella thick we got the
the duck
feet in the back i love threes i haven't
worn threes for a while
but even looking at these i'm like man i
need to start wearing threes again like
this is just um
you know one of those three top three
jordans of all time
the red octobers yay just killed these
and honestly like
this was definitely an inspiration
behind my flooded green ones
you know this was kind of the first like
real flooded shoe
that i couldn't think of they're just
special man
there was so much hype around them for
so long like when they were gonna come
out we thought they were gonna come out
they didn't come out we thought you know
and then finally they just kind of came
out of nowhere
they're a half size too small
i don't care i don't care there's a
performance that we did
in times square for the ball drop
new year's eve and i'm wearing a pair of
red octobers
you know the most sought after shoe that
you can possibly get
and i took my red octobers off my feet
and i threw them into the crowd at times
square
those were fake i would never throw
these into a crowd
okay but great great great publicity you
know
oh my god macklemore threw his shoes
into the crowd
those are worth twelve thousand dollars
those were 250
on the internet okay they were fake as
hell
but they looked real one of my defining
moments
as a human let's look at these let's
throw them in
this is another one i mean i'm not
putting these in the top five i think
that
but we could throw them in for the
purpose of this i think that
they're just a great design this
colorway i don't think has aged quite as
well
in terms of the like fluorescent pink
but this was very much like pink polo
yay
era a throwback to that you know if you
were to play like glow-in-the-dark
laser tag like these would be a shoe to
wear because [ __ ] would just
know where you're at at all times
but they're really dope they're a
classic
yeah i think that what kanye has been
able to do
at adidas is have probably more
creative say in his
line than he would have at nike so i
think that if he went back to nike it
would be awesome
you know for him to get a stake i think
that there is something
he is such a defining
pivotal person in terms of setting
trends that he should be rewarded as
such
like on the financial end um not just
like yeah man we'll let you do some
shoes
but like no like actually you get a
stake in this shoe
um there's ownership there i believe
that that's where yay is at and really
where a lot of celebrities are at in
terms of you know putting their stamp on
things and making [ __ ] cool
um you know these brands as much as we
love them have not necessarily been
as kind to some of the other athletes
that have made them what they are and
nike has always had that poll where it's
just like yeah if you want to [ __ ] with
us like we're not giving you a bag
or the bag is small and um i think that
it's time to usher in a new era where
people
are rewarded for their their
creative influence where they're
rewarded for their social capital
and not just like yeah we'll give you
free [ __ ] like that's cool
but kanye is on a different level right
choose your now three and take the other
two off
if i was to narrow this down to three
i'm gonna get rid of these
i mean i got to get rid of i mean i'm
i'm
this is the foundation this is the
foundation
this is what started it all these ones
right here
i'm not getting rid of them
all right you're not gonna like my final
question for you i want you to choose
one pair to wear one pair to sell
and one pair of keys um yeah i mean can
we go back now because i'd like to sell
these red octobers
um one pair to wear for the rest of my
life
i mean these this is what this is what
i'm gonna wear
okay for the rest of my life i can
always wear these
if i i'm gonna i gotta wear one i gotta
sew and i gotta keep one
right these aren't worse particularly in
this state
uh so i'm probably gonna get like 35 on
craigslist
so let's just say we're gonna sell these
the pit crews
could probably make a little bit of
bread out these i don't know maybe
35 hundo five racks and then we're gonna
keep these for nostalgia steak
okay just there's something about this
is my childhood
so i'm gonna keep these i'm gonna wear
these
and these are getting put up on
[Music]
yourself stockx would you like to see
come on the show you know who really
hasn't done
a sneaker show who i would love to see
michael jordan
have we really seen jordan talk about
shoes like that
like go through and you know memories
and design process
and i haven't seen jordan do it so i
would love to see jordan do it i think
that that would be amazing
obviously there was shoes that probably
he wasn't feeling at the time that ended
up
becoming iconic who knows i would love
to see that